yeah miles is Big on this video for
reference this is how hairy my butt is
right now oh God oh God
[Applause]
YouTube 26 million go back to it because
I was on YouTube I don't know epic 720
goes this is unreal so we can't say and
this [__] show is straight
[__]
that's what I want to bring up bro it's
crazy okay go go go I'm not doing it
again well I'm not write it back yeah at
least pause it go back go back at least
this is how hairy my butt is right now
whoa
yeah I think that yeah I was like I
don't know what that is the AI played
hold on [__] insane
okay go
all right so let's narrow it this cream
onto your hand so I'm going to be doing
just that
oh now it says to apply a thick even
layer to cover the whole thing it's
really just the jump scare oh
oh [__] yes we gotta watch the ocean yo
that's crazy how is this okay
don't forget to cover the cheeks as well
setting a timer for three minutes don't
get worse than 40 minutes because I did
that with my armpits I go into five
minutes and it literally burned and
stung so bad so stick to three I'm gonna
go wash my hands now real fast we have
one minute left so far there's no
stinging nothing's hurting it's all good
check small area I think your hair may
require more time so let's check a small
area first taking like my damp paper
towel that I got from the kitchen oh
[__] dude
so some hairs came off but I put a
little bit more time okay I'm just gonna
like swipe it because like yeah
that is cool it's on YouTube come on
come on come on
apparently he's trying he's trying to
learn right now
crazy his ass is nothing bro I looked it
up apparently because it's educational
it can be on there put it put it this
way his ass looked like I could put on
it compared to my house
go keep going keep going
yesterday so I'm just gonna like avoid
that and like just hope for the best
that was one swipe that was me and
Amalfi every time
you know it's bad I can't even look up
he can't even look up bro half the
people in your country is like that
yo come on
does he get it all like give me the end
give me the end fast forward yo that's
oh it works
look at that one it's pretty good better
that they sent that to me I didn't know
what it was
wild said you were dying to show this to
us nah that's funny I would have well
that was great yeah but it did work Nair
does work and I wonder if the girl would
have because the first time she looked
at she went for it the second time she
didn't really
go for it in the same way and I wonder
it's because it's so hairy that's funny
I don't have hair on my [__] I have
it like not in the cheeks like right
where the split's about to start that's
where the hair is yeah so I think mine
goes down into the whole of it I shave
that [__] wait what yeah you shave it
I'm not shave on or whatever yeah but
really yeah interesting too much hair
but for what purpose I don't want to get
into your sex life too much but not just
if I'm gonna do here I was like I might
as well
the clippers but like you put your
where it doesn't have to be that great
of a job you just go right there gone
interesting yeah
looking at me wild crazy right now so
I'm like oh okay bro yeah it's like just
that much hair imagine when you wipe
after a [__] you got [__] in the head
all right guys we'll take a break from
this exclusive patreon clip because I
gotta tell y'all about the best dicks in
the business okay yours your dick is the
best dick in a business you might not
know it because you're not chewed up in
blued up but you can be same active
ingredients that's inside Viagra Cialis
but this is blue chew this is the one
that we rock with this is the one that
we stay married with satisfied satisfied
customers and you can get it for free
did you know that all you gotta do is
pay five dollars shipping okay you get
the best bonus of your life five dollar
shipping go to bluetooth.com make sure
you use the promo code flagrant now
let's get back to this exclusive patreon
clip join our patreon patreon.com
flagrant thank you very much I've taken
multiple shits wiped and then there was
a piece of [__] hanging on the hair that
I didn't know about that's what I'm
saying and then wiped it across my whole
ass and then I would sit back down and
keep wiping and sit back down and keep
wiping and then I go up and I look at
the toilet seat and there was [__]
smeared all over the toilet seat because
a little piece of [__]
and then I just said
you did this so the stuff his girl gotta
go through like she she
loves it how to wipe properly no I did
but I didn't learn how to account for a
piece of [__] getting caught up in the
hair yeah so why don't you shave it yeah
I got it waxed once when I was younger
it was for a roll but it was great okay
but when you man skate yeah just
manscape back there too I do the taint a
bit
wait so you just go taint and nothing
around it anything that I can see from
here I do
I'll do the taint a bit oh wait you
shave yeah yeah every once in a while
everyone
I'm Indian man at the end of the day but
wait oh wait oh are you managing back
here uh no I have like uh like a little
patch on like the top of my arm which is
weird do you shave that no no she's look
her dad is a hairy [__] you this
ain't bothering you but this is like at
a certain point is disrespectful to whom
to my wife really yeah interesting
yes you need to man skate more bro I
mean I shaved my balls and [__] I'm not
going to shave a region that you not how
long what how long before like in
between shapes yes uh mostly if I feel
insecure
like if I feel sad about something or if
I feel down I do it as like a control
metric control thing it's like Britney
shaving her head or like the girls who
cut themselves
it's like girls who cut but also
Brittany yeah pretty shavings
girls cut they're just like I just need
to control a part of my life and I feel
that and I shave and I'm like oh wow
yeah my dick is beautiful my balls are
awesome
hey I'll never do that that's you
controlling your life that's me shaving
your teeth when I can't control anything
else I control that that's what maybe
it's like you probably do that it's like
once a month like regularly if you have
a regular shaving yeah no it's not me
like I don't let it get that long
like a beard yeah beer grows in that
[__] grows in too once a month do you
shave your beard or do you get it shaved
depends if I want to look clean then
I'll go to a place but I usually do this
I did myself really yeah
and you know how to get it trimmed and
everything yeah I use a straight blade
what do you do that too nah I tried it I
[__] up cut myself
here and here
yeah straight blade my dad actually no
he got me like the single blade razor
and I would do that I need like a blade
maybe a straight blade but even then bro
well I'm doing all this for something
this takes two seconds bang you look
great
come on bro do you like looking good
um you know what select
Ive hey can I tell you something you
care about like sometimes yeah
selectively but like when you look good
like you're like I feel good oh my God
this is nice and then other times I'm
like I gotta [__] go to the barber
and it's the whole thing yes learn to do
it yourself then it's like a quick
little thing and it's like ah I feel
good I'll trim it down but I won't do
straight blade I trim this down as I
over trim this time but I'll trim it
down myself but then over trim I thought
too like you have the guard on the
Clippers yeah and I was like let me go
down because I felt like I wanted to be
lower and then it now it's nice but when
I first cut this like Thursday or Friday
or whatever day I got back I was like oh
this is too low you wouldn't understand
because you're you know I don't know so
it's like if if you use the same like uh
level of trimmer everywhere some spots
are going to be lighter than others so
you have to like go a little more on the
thick areas and a little less on the
fins my mustache I always go lower than
my beard ah it seems so stressful that's
a lot I'm saying yeah something it ain't
worth looking it's crazy I'll never know
what that's like yeah isn't that crazy
yeah but you know you can like do stuff
to get a beard but it seems it is a lot
of work but it's like you do that thing
but it actually works you think yeah it
does is it worth it or does it become
more nuisance I mean if you want a beard
it's worth it if you don't care about
having one then I guess nothing get it
laser removed I prayed for pubes when I
was younger
how old were you when that's what it
took for you to believe in God smooth
balls no yeah yeah yeah
and I I prayed for them I prayed I was
like please God why how long did it take
for you to get here no but God answered
in like a horrendous way
so I
I'm very careful about what I pray for
that's why he's not religious
God listens guys God is two power God is
very powerful like that's funny yeah but
he doesn't give you a problem that you
can't handle or whatever you said
earlier so your boy's out here handling
there you go okay let's do some patrons
yo [__] what's up I'm uh at work I'm
gonna keep this short like uh [__] boy
Miles said all right he's getting a lot
of [__] now yeah
uh question for uh ow
look at me look at me I'm white but my
dad's black am I allowed to say the
n-word keep it a buck
keep it flagrant